this video was made possible by
brilliant learn complex topics simply
for 20% off by being one of the first
two hundred to sign up at brilliant org
slash wind over twenty years ago the
Western world didn't really think of
China as a market the country was an
asset for the West's own market sure but
only for the reason that it was a large
poor country that could act as a source
of low-cost labor today though with an
economy ten times larger than that of
just twenty years ago the Western world
or at least the properly informed
Western world no longer thinks of China
as that poor low-cost labor asset a
rather as a significant attractive
market itself whereas in the past China
made for the West today China is the
very market that the Western world
focuses their attention on with a
rapidly growing middle and upper-class
businesses around the world have flooded
in to cater to China's newly wealthy in
the same way that they have long served
the rich in the wealthy Western world
industries ranging from hospitality to
tourism to e-commerce to beauty and more
are all thriving there with both
homegrown and foreign-born players
establishing their spots in the Chinese
market but one enormous industry that is
still emerging and evolving in the
Middle Kingdom is that of sports sports
is a Monstress global industry but
nowhere is that industry more enormous
than in the US the NFL MLB NBA and NHL
represent the first second fourth and
six most valuable sports leagues in the
world and collectively bring in more
than thirty billion dollars in annual
revenue however American sports are not
purely an American industry between
merchandising league partnerships TV and
streaming rights and other revenue
streams American sports leagues actually
earn a considerable amount of money
outside of America China is a market
worth targeting for any business but it
has a particular appeal for sports
leagues beyond its status as a large and
relatively recently wealthy nation China
has a government willing and interested
in investing in foreign sports the kind
of foreign sports that would earn them
prestige in international competitions
each of the four major American sports
leagues are the dominant leagues
the world for the respective sports so
any interest in each sport will lead to
interest in their league consequentially
each league has its own strategy to grow
Chinese interest both in their sport and
their league baseball is incredibly
popular in nearby Taiwan South Korea and
Japan and so there was a reason to
believe that the sport could to become
popular in China despite this though
Major League Baseball has demonstrated
the least interest in the market and the
market has demonstrated the least
interest in the MLB the league's most
tangible effort to attract Chinese
audiences took place back in 2008 when
two preseason games between the Padres
and Dodgers were played in Beijing since
then the history of baseball in China
has been fraught with difficulties with
their national league which operated in
cooperation with the American MLB
suspending operations in 2012 restarting
in 2014
suspending operations again in 2016 then
starting up again in 2019 with just four
teams the MLB has also long operated
three development centers where top
Chinese baseball players are trained
although none of the players from these
centers have ever actually seen action
in the MLB itself one can find press
release upon press release about
different renewed efforts by the MLB to
grow the sport in China however all
signs indicate that these have not
resulted in much evidence of this can be
seen on the league's official Weibo
accounts one of the top social networks
in China which has only 650 thousand
followers the story is not markedly
different with the NHL but history of
its efforts is shorter it put on
exhibition matches between the kings and
Canucks in Shanghai and Beijing in 2017
then between the Bruins and flames in
Beijing and Shenzhen in 2018 these games
were generally well-received and were
attended by healthy sized audiences but
there was a conspicuous lack of
follow-up with no 2019 games in China
reportedly due to issues with booking
arenas
since then though they've doubled down
sending Stanley Cup champion Alex
Ovechkin to the country in summer 2019
to promote the sport opening an office
in Beijing and hiring a China marketing
head unfortunately for them though the
little attention china pays to hockey is
not primarily directed
to the NHL the second most lucrative
hockey league in the world the
Kontinental Hockey League added a
Chinese team in 2016 the HC Kunlun red
star the team is no phenomenon yet with
the lowest average game attendance in
the league but it does mean that a
Chinese hockey fan would much more
likely pay attention to the KHL over the
NHL still though the NHL seems to get
somewhat more respectable Chinese
engagement demonstrated by their just
over 1 million fans on Weibo American
football though is where it starts to
get interesting the NFL has generated a
real fan base among Chinese not a large
one but it certainly exists this is
despite the fact that they are the only
of the four leagues that has not played
a game in China there is talk of putting
one on in the country at the start of
the 2020 season although there's been
talk before without result
the real potential for the NFL though
comes not through in country games but
rather through digital distribution each
week 10 cents streaming platforms
broadcast a number of games which each
have an average viewership of more than
2 million people that's despite the
awkward broadcast times in the mid
morning given the time difference how
much the NFL was paid for these
broadcast rights is not publicly known
but with those kind of numbers it's
certainly not nothing beyond the league
as a-holes efforts the New England
Patriots have put a particular level of
effort into attracting Chinese fans a
huge benefit for them is that their star
Tom Brady has been learning and speaks a
rudimentary level of Mandarin he hosted
a Chinese language show for the team's
digital channels which attracted
sizeable attention over 15 million total
views meanwhile playing the sport itself
is increasingly popular in China having
one's children learn the American sport
has emerged as a status symbol and
120,000 young Chinese have gone to
private training camps for American
football still though the NFL has a long
way to go to make China a sizable
portion of its business on Weibo for
example it is only attracted slightly
more fans than the NHL and 1.3 million
the final of these four leagues though
has turned China into a sizeable and now
crucial bit of its business basketball
has been played casually in China since
the late 1800s when American
missionaries first introduced the sport
as China liberalized in the latter half
of the 20th century the NBA capitalized
on this and then commissioner David
Stern led an effort to get their games
televised in China this attracted a
moderate fan base but the true pivotal
moment happened in 2002 in that year a
young player from the Shanghai Sharks
entered the NBA Draft and was picked
first overall
Yao Ming he quickly became a sensation
and reached the NBA all-star team eight
times but as much as he was a sensation
in the u.s. he was just as much or more
back home in China the number of Chinese
NBA fans grew exponentially with every
game he played but eventually after a
series of injury plagued seasons Ming
retired in 2011 at the time anyone would
have assumed that this would have been
the end of the NBA's rise in China but
as it turned out this was not the case
well at first Chinese fans may have
tuned in to watch young Ming eventually
they just tuned in to watch the NBA in
the decade following Ming's retirements
China grew into an enormous crucial part
of the NBA's business representing more
than a five hundred million dollars a
year in revenue however in October 2019
this was all threatened by one tweet
containing one image it read fight for
freedom stand with Hong Kong this was of
course a reference in support of the
widespread protests in Hong Kong
protests commonly characterized as anti
Beijing but what's more important is who
this tweet was by Darrell Marais the
general manager of the Houston Rockets
all of a sudden deals fell apart
relationships were severed game
broadcasts were canceled the NBA's China
market was under threat due to a
perception that the league was anti
China unsurprisingly for business
reasons the NBA quickly issued what was
essentially an apology for this tweet of
course following
the NBA both faced criticism from China
for the original tweet and from the US
for apologizing for that tweet
eventually the scandal largely blew over
and relationships started to inch back
to normal but this was all indicative of
a bigger issue with Americans forces
expansion into China what these leagues
are doing is selling one product to two
very different markets worldwide the
entertainment industry of which Sports
is a part of has become increasingly
homogenized with more and more people
watching the same TV shows listening to
the same music and going to the same
movies no matter which country or
culture they come from China meanwhile
is different Chinese people largely
watch different TV shows listen to
different music and go to different
movies and the rest of us a lot of this
is because of government censorship and
import policy for example there's a
quota allowing only a small number of
foreign films into Chinese cinemas each
year sports though can't be treated like
the rest of entertainment the sports
entertainment experience in the 21st
century stretches far beyond just the
viewing of actual games in fact watching
the games in their entirety is hardly
even a requirement anymore Sports is an
all-encompassing unscripted uncensored
entertainment experience and this is the
problem for children it can't just add
it out an unflattering aspect of sports
in the same way I can with foreign films
sports and politics in the US are
intrinsically intertwined many athletes
naturally take their place as political
activists given their influence but this
is very different from in China in China
Sports is a game where athletes go and
play someone wins and then everyone goes
home that's because in China
entertainment and politics stay far far
away from each other or perhaps more
accurately entertainment and opposition
politics stay far far away from each
other American sports will continue
their march towards increased relevancy
in China as it as a country as an under
saturated spectator sports market
meanwhile though if these leagues become
a true phenomenon in China
we'll have to make more tough calls as
to whether they want to be a sports
league for the US or for the world in my
opinion the behind the scenes of sports
is fascinating if you agree but feel
you've gotten enough of the business
side for now
you can learn a little more about the
physics side you can learn how climbers
figure out how elastic their rope should
be elastic enough to not give them
whiplash when they fall but not elastic
enough to let them hit the ground you
can learn how energy transforms when a
skier descends a slope you can learn how
archers account for gravity in their aim
and you can learn all of this on
brilliance these are just some of the
interesting engaging things that you can
learn about while you're actually
learning classical mechanics on
brilliance something decisively less
engaging than climbing skiing or archery
the teaching and learning style is what
makes brilliant is so effective for the
kind of things that you might want to
learn but previously were too daunted -
if your new year's resolution was to
learn more to improve yourself or to
challenge yourself brilliant is the
place to start they help you achieve
your goals in stem and to make it easier
the first 200 people that go to
brilliant org slash mind over will get
20% off an annual premium subscription